je vous l'annoncé également voilà ça
c'est un petit scoop
je vous l'annonçais il y aura une
nouvelle émission également une fois par
semaine
en prime time
animée par mme ou moi-même à ce conte
qui va être à tous qu on va faire un
nouveau talk ah voilà on direct après
une émission avec louis avec des
rigolades et sa femme danielle réunit
des invités de toutes parts politiques
des acteurs des chanteurs à des paris
car pour l'instant il y aura un mois
n'ont pas forcément on est en train de
voir le jour sachez que ça va arriver ça
va arriver dès la rentrée des énormes
mathieu ça va arriver très très vite
plus vite qu'on ne le croit voilà ça
c'est sûr ça ne me dit pas où vous allez
gagner
non vraiment c'est ok sachez que les
autres vous verrez tout au long de la
semaine et je tiendrais au courant bien
entendu les téléspectateurs
de qui quand où comment combien
sachets aujourd'hui que vous avez une
personne autour de la table
qui est
qu à passer un cap qui nous a pris de
l'oseille il a passé un cap dans la
société c'est une personne aujourd'hui
il va vivre aisément
et c'est une personne qui ne vous
considérera plus faire mais sachez le
ici les benhaim castaldi vdev di mauro
autres seront des dix petit poucet je le
connais quand il a l'âme ou là
il à la race rare et donc il dire fou
bien et tu es heureux ouais je suis bien
new york tiens pourquoi je sens qu'il ya
mais non non mais j'ai mal à d'abord
parce que j'ai rien signé ok avec vous
je devais avoir un problème je vais
partir en patagonie ou en laponie je
sais pas où j'allais faire plein de
trucs ici je n'ai jamais rien vu
dernièrement touché fait du karaté on
devait partir en thaïlande on en est où
éclate ayant alors
alors là taillon tu vas partir mais avec
ce nouveau seuil je ne panique pas
ces messieurs mais en vrai si je signe
un contrat comme ça en vrai je suis
super content et je suis super content
la patronne parce que c'est vrai que tu
vas pas eh ben tu as fait john n'a à ma
patronne avait pas encore au courant
je suis arrivé la mort il m'a dit série
me parlent et je crois toujours partie
voir ma patronne
ça va vite avec toi tu as ta vente
annoncée des trucs comme ça et puis
demain il faut que je fasse un faux que
je nettoie
[Rires]
c'était je t'aurais dit par contre l'ess
mois le temps de l'annoncé mal à parler
tu m'as dit que c'était des écoutes
avait vu avec elle khaled alors que
j'aime beaucoup est ce que tu veux que
j'appelle la là tout de suite je pense
pas non
non non et non pas son nom c'est pas les
gens comme nicolas tavernost les gens de
la télé michel cymes ma patronne c'est
pas des gens comme ça c'est à dire ben
je vais pas la déranger il ya énormément
de respect tu ne respectes pas
c'est que plus le temps passe plus ton
contrat si nulle part c'est pour ça que
je disais qu'en tant que j'ai pas soin
de sa bombe a tout le temps promis des
choses qui sont jamais venus maya
footballeur on m'a dit que je ferais de
la radio
sur sa promesse vas-y fais toi la viande
rouge alors moi j'attends de voir ja
tournant pas l'appeler chili un grand
sens de la persuasion avoir tout cas en
tout cas c'est une grosse pour vous le
reste great radôme a redit ce que tu
veux dire que vous avez un grand sens de
la persuasion signera son contrat demain
les qui rajoute vous êtes magnifique et
très élégant près de matinée tout montre
à ce soir
[Applaudissements]